well you know it's funny you say that
because I don't think of greed is
exactly the problem on Wall Street I
think greed is sort of a professional
obligation on Wall Street I mean not
being greedy on Wall Street is like not
not wanting to be funny for a comedian
you just if you're there you've got to
want to make money and the problem is
when the people when the greedy people
are wrongly incentivized so that instead
of being sent avise to take really smart
long-term risks they're incentivized to
take huge risks that so that if they
work out even the short-term they get
pay huge sums of money and if they don't
work out it's not their problem take a
long away from it I think if you if the
system of incentives was right the greed
wouldn't matter the greed would be
properly channeled the grades of fuel
and it just needs to be properly
channeled now and i saw i think that it
you know the premise of your question is
if people were just better people people
if people were less self-interested this
would this wouldn't have happened that
might be true ah it's on it's moot
because the kind of people are going to
end up on Wall Street are never going to
be not self-interested it's not going to
happen so you're just going to be very
careful about the system the incentives
that control that greed having said all
that I don't want to contradict myself
entirely but I do it but it is one of
the forces underpinning this debacle is
the change in financial expectations of
the people who are in Wall Street it's a
little different from greed but it's
what they consider to be a normal sum of
money to make and if everybody is
operating with the assumption that the
normal big payday is a million dollars
they do behave one way if they all
operate with the assumption that the
normal big payday is a hundred million
dollars or even a billion dollars well
they behave another way and the other
way they behave is by taking a lot more
risk because the only way you generate
those sums of money is by taking here
huge risk so there was there was this
thing that happened in the Wall Street
mind over the last 25 years where the
just the the level of financial
expectations it's a little different
from greed it's just sort of like the
level of it what what is what is what
are we supposed to make changed and what
we're going through right now is a
radical downward readjustment